make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob and
because you really seem to like our
previous video with Deadpool killing the
DC Universe I thought we would pick up
where we left off and follow Deadpool
into the other universes that he travels
to and so today we're gonna focus on his
efforts to kill the Star Wars universe
and I think this is an interesting
proposition because as we know Deadpool
is constantly breaking the fourth wall
and so we certainly seen the Star Wars
movies meaning that he will know when
and where characters are going to be at
any given point in time and also since
Star Wars comics are published by Marvel
this could theoretically happen one day
depending on how desperate for sales
Marvel is at the time but anyway because
Deadpool is familiar with the Star Wars
continuity he knows where to go and win
in order to maximize his kill count and
so for this story he's going to start in
Cloud City during the Empire Strikes
Back
specifically the scene where Darth Vader
hires a group of bounty hunters to find
the Millennium Falcon and in this scene
we see six bounty hunters of course with
Boba Fett being the most notable but we
also see Bosque ig-88 for long suckas
and dengar now it's interesting cuz I
didn't know those those bounty hunters
had names to be honest with you guys
thought they were just guys who were
there what I think is technically their
group name right like Boba Fett and the
guys who were there so like a band but
regardless Deadpool is going to know
that this is not the time to take on
Darth Vader and so he'll basically lurk
in the shadows of the ships corridors
until the bounty hunters make their way
to their respective shifts so that he
does not have to deal with Vader right
now and so once the opportunity presents
itself
Deadpool leaps into action first
targeting dengar because he is
objectively the lamest of all the bounty
hunters and probably the easiest to take
out with him out of the way he turns his
attention to the Droid bounty hunters
4-lom in ig-88 and then attaches a
device to each of them that interferes
with their programming and basically
shuts them down which for a Droid is
equivalent to killing I guess but that
leaves boss sucka sim Bubba Fett who by
now have all realized Deadpool's
presence and are firing on him now while
this might seem like the odds are
against Deadpool in this steep situation
keep in mind that he is going to know
what he's up against before he goes in
and he's going to bring along sufficient
firepower to get the job done meaning
basically he's gonna be bringing bigger
guns to a fight than any of the bounty
hunters have and so once he's able to
use this advantage in weaponry to take
out suckas and
we get to the fight that everybody wants
to see here Deadpool vs. Boba Fett what
some might call a battle of the two most
overexposed characters going today and
before you guys run to the comments
remember I'm not saying that they're
overexposed I'm just saying that it's an
opinion some people might hold it's the
correct opinion but is an opinion
nonetheless now Boba Fett is able to
prolong his fight for a bit as he has
some pretty impressive weaponry
including his flamethrower as well as
his armor and his jet pack and so he
presents a bit of a challenge for
Deadpool but Deadpool is able to evade
Boba's attacks long enough that he
ultimately gets frustrated and then
engages Deadpool in close combat which
ultimately would be his undoing as
Deadpool proves himself to be the
superior fighter and so the fight ends
with Deadpool decapitating Boba Fett in
a nod to the fate that his father
suffered in the prequels and Deadpool of
course would make some kind of a comment
like man that fight lasted twice as long
as all the screen time you had in the
original trilogy it now Deadpool would
then pick up and put on Boba Fett's
armor and jetpack because he realizes
that he's killed Boba Fett right before
he does the one meaningful thing he does
in the entire trilogy leave the Empire
to Cloud City and so he decides that
he'll simply just impersonate him for a
while and so Deadpool takes off enslave
one Boba Fett ship and sets off for
Cloud City where he knows the Millennium
Falcon is headed and relays the
information of the Falcons whereabouts
to Darth Vader now he arrives at Cloud
City and things go down just like they
do in the movies
up until Han Solo is frozen in carbonite
my Deadpool still disguised as Boba Fett
takes possession of solo but instead of
delivering him straight to Jabba the
Hutt he flies his ship to the bottom of
the vent where Luke Skywalker's
lightsaber falls during his duel with
Darth Vader figuring that this is the
easiest way to procure a lightsaber and
so when the sable falls into an open
hatch on slave 1 it's immediately
followed by Luke severed hand and so
Deadpool picks up the lightsaber put it
on and says this will come in handy and
then he picks up the severed hand saying
and this will get me a lot of money on
e-bay
which is true because you guys know
somebody's gonna buy it right there's
always that one guy but Deadpool would
then make his way to Jabba's palace on
Tatooine he would turn Han Solo over to
Jabba and then collect his bounty and so
he hangs out until Lando Chewbacca and
Leia show up to rescue Han of course
Lando having been there for a little
while and Deadpool knows this he's just
playing it low-key
now he allows
all of them to break Han Solo free of
the Carbonite but as soon as they do he
emerges from the shadows now brandishing
his lightsaber and so as Han is
operating without his side at this point
and Chewbacca is without his blaster
since he was taken prisoner neither of
them is any match for a lightsaber
wielding Deadpool and so Deadpool will
comment well that was probably a lamer
death and they deserved although
probably less embarrassing and getting
stabbed by your incredibly emo son which
is true right kylo Ren I'm so
misunderstood by the world dad is so
conformist right like waving his hair
out of his out of his face was like the
emo kids of South Park
you guys remember them that's basically
kylo Ren but with only Leia left alive
he hesitates while deciding her fate now
in his moment of hesitation Leia reaches
for her blaster which prompts Deadpool
to strike her down with his lightsaber
musing that if she knew what Jabba had
in store for her she'd likely rather be
dead anyway
no I this time Jabba and everyone else
in the palace has basically woken up and
Java sends his guards to apprehend
Deadpool but he pulls Leia's thermal
detonator from her belt and then throws
it toward Java and his guards and so the
explosion takes out everybody in the
palace and it would have taken out
Deadpool too if it weren't for his
healing factor and so after he's
recovered he gets back in slave one
travels around the galaxy spending his
bounty since imperial credits won't work
once he leaves the universe and when the
time is right he heads to the second
Death Star in anticipation of the final
battle between Darth Vader and Luke
Skywalker now something that I do want
to point out here is that in return to
the Jedi that Luke Skywalker did show up
right like he did show up to Tatooine in
order to confront Jabba the hype and
then he showed up when you just found
everybody was dead and was just like
damn this sucks you know and probably
cried a little bit and then left
that's basically what it would be right
so like maybe he still fights the rancor
I don't know maybe he's just like I need
to take my rage out on something and
then like he hears a noise or he senses
it with the force and then like instead
of being tricked to go down there like
being dropped down there by Java he just
like goes down there kills it and then
leaves but who knows does it really
matter
and so Deadpool would arrive just as
Luke and Vader's lightsaber duel is
beginning and so he clears his throat
and both of them divert their attention
to him now he ignites his saber and he
says all right let's do this before
rushing in to join the fray and within
seconds his lightsaber hits the floor
followed by both
arms so deep will becoming okay
so maybe I was a little out of my depth
here with the lightsaber skills and the
force and all that you guys just go back
to what you were doing and I'm just
gonna stay here and come up with a new
strategy now assuming that Deadpool is
effectively useless because he doesn't
have the use of his arms Luke and Darth
Vader go back to fighting one another
and once Deadpool has regrown his arms
he gets back into the battle with his
new plan which is an extremely intricate
and nuanced one he's gonna use guns and
so knowing that he's in a room with
three very proficient users of the force
he knows he's going to have to do
something to interrupt their focus and
strike at each of them before they can
get their bearings and just redirect the
bullets back at him although they
probably wouldn't even know what to do
anyway because they have no concept of
bullets but regardless he deploys some
flash grenades to draw their attention
to the area of the explosion and then
opens fire on both of them with a
machine gun that he conveniently brought
away the Death Star with him and so
after Vader and Luke have both been
mowed down the Emperor starts cackling
from his throne right very good very
impressive you show much potential join
me rule the galaxy by my side and I will
train you in the ways of the dark side i
just want to say darth Deadpool sounds
amazing it sounds like an awesome idea
and so Deadpool looks heading for a
moment as of contemplating his offer
before replying you know I'm gonna pass
on that I'm not great on the whole
apprentice thing I'd be happy to kill
you though that's kind of what I came
here to do besides the fate that awaits
you in the most recent Star Wars movie
if you knew that was gonna happen
you'd probably want to die anyway
because it was terrible you know it's
terrible everybody who saw it knows it's
terrible you would probably end up
regretting it and so the Emperor smirks
at him and says okay whatever
before hitting Deadpool with Force
Lightning now to his surprise Deadpool
endures the pain of the lightning and
keeps advancing on the Emperor and so
even when he ups the anticip Deadpool's
healing factor is able to shrug it off
and he keeps coming at the Emperor now
once he finally reaches him the Emperor
stares in shock at the pain tolerance of
Deadpool who's able to turn on his
lightsaber and bury it into the
Emperor's chest killing him and so
Deadpool would look at this and then
kind of remark you know I should have
done the flippy lightsaber stuff from
the prequels it would have been a lot
cooler even though I didn't serve any
useful purpose and so satisfied with the
amount of carnage that he's caused
Deadpool turns to leave the Star Wars
universe before something out of the
window catches his eye
forest moon of Endor he turns to the
reader and he says you might want to
look away this could get ugly but I just
absolutely hate Ewoks and then the story
will come to a close yes ladies and
gentlemen Deadpool is going to Massacre
the Ewoks would that be said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here two comments explain make
sure you guys have a sub button to
become part of the rob4 if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]